ومن جهته قال زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
ياير لابيد ان المنظومه السياسيه الحاليه
في اسرائيل هي المشكله وليست الحل وفي
كلمه امام الكنيست قال لابيد انه لم يرى
اسرائيل حزينه مثل هذا اليوم مشيرا الى
فقدان مزيد من الجنود وتضاؤل الامل في
عوده
الاسرى المنظومه السياسيه اليوم في وضعها
الحالي هي المشكله وليست الحل علينا ان
نسال انفسنا كيف وصلنا الى هذا الوضع منذ
عشت في هذه الدوله لم تكن حزينه مثل اليوم
الناس مكسورون وممزق القلوب على العائلات
على المختطفين على الجنود الذين يقتلون
كيف وصلنا الى هذا الحال دوله عظمى في
الشرق الاوسط محاطه بتنظيم ارهابي يخترق
الحدود بسيارات دفع رباعي ويقتل مواطنيها
وابنائها مئات الالاف يجلون من بيوتهم ولا
نعلم متى سيعودون
136 مختطفا لدى حماس احد يعلم متى سيعودون
الى اين نحن
ذاهبون